Sometimes, using a library
is the right answer.
While they can hide
implementation details,
they make complex scenarios much
easier to deal with and can soften
some of the sharp edges compared
to hand-rolling your own solution.
Service Worker Precache is a node
module for auto-magically generating
a service worker that will
precache your AppShell resources.
By adding a few extra configuration
parameters, you can also define
runtime caching options,
perfect for our application data.
The module is designed for
use with Gulp or
Grunt build scripts, though it also
provides a command line interface.
The module's API provides a method for
creating a service worker and
saving the resulting code to a file.
The advantage of including
it in your build script
is that it can automatically run,
whenever a file changes.
You don't need to manually
update it every time.